to ukraine now and two british men and a
moroccan had been sentenced to death in
the donetsk region of ukraine that's
under occupation by russia and its proxy
forces the prime minister says the
government must do everything possible
to secure the release of the two british
men aiden aslan and sean pinner and the
moroccan man who was a 21 year old
ibrahim sadhu surrendered in maripol in
april that of course was when he was
captured along with the two
brits by russian forces
now his friend zinatenko is a 22 year
old ukrainian woman she came here to the
uk through the sponsorship scheme she's
now living with her mum at a host family
near sheffield she joins us now thank
you so much for being with us it must be
such a difficult time for you so we do
appreciate you speaking to us um just
talk to us about ibrahim he's a 21 year
old moroccan he moved to keeve to study
you met him in a nightclub i think
yeah yeah i met him and keep my club k51
uh on the
floor uh thankful to our
common friends
from america and jikhonda tillentowner
and jake
um
i met him and
just from the start we
had a nice conversation
um he opened his heart to me and as
i
to him
very open-minded person
and very kind and
just from the start he also mentioned
that he is aimed to join our army
ukrainian army and he already tried
several times to join that but
unfortunately
he needed to gain some weight
so
he even cheated he was drinking water
before
the community
to gain some weight and
yeah so they can accept him and he can
join our army so he managed to
go to marines
to protect us uh it was yeah before the
full-scale invasion started
what a story and i have to say like from
the images of him he does look like
quite a slight
guy like he's obviously quite young but
he does look like quite a slight guy
that so i can imagine drinking water
story it does does yeah it wasn't
thrilled at all
um
it's important of course to talk about
how he joined the ukrainian army because
it obviously goes against the sham trial
the claims that are in russia that he
was mercenary he was clearly
fighting on behalf of ukraine along with
the two british men as well
just explain how did he end up fighting
in mario paul how does someone go from a
nightclub and keeve to
the the fight in mariopol
well um
in
kiev nightclub especially if we are
talking about k-41 knight club
the
that's place that's a place for all of
the people
that's lgbtqs plus friendly nightclub
and there's no prejustice no
discrimination so the place like we want
ukraine to be and to others to see
ukraine like this
so this club is more about the community
uh we had a lot of our national stars
dancing in there even the advice of
president is dancing the
lesson called so and he mentions is it
on instagram even
in his profile that he's a raver
yes it's more about community all of the
people
go to this nightclub
it's about
who you are and not
which music do you prefer
and when did you last
when did you last here from ibrahim
it was
you know early it was in the early march
and what was happening at the time
yeah he was uh posting some photos from
his um
drama he was put since a photo from army
and i was just asking here what is that
because it looks so hilarious
so he was explaining me how he was
living in there
and
yeah
he usually say everything is all right
everything is okay
uh do not worry about me and that's
what he continues to say right now if
you
managed to
see the last video
he recorded for his mother and father
for his family
and
even now he's assuring his mom mom don't
worry about me and he's looking at the
camera and he's smiling that's the
person who
he is
exactly
his
portrait
very cheerful person
it's quite moving thinking if you know
the 21 year old you know who's got this
death sentence trying to reassure his
mum that you know everything will be
okay and i'm sure how concerned you and
his family must be
what would you what would your message
be to you know the uk government to the
moroccan government
what do you want to see happen
please care about people who hear about
democracy because people
and our actions of common people our
lives that's the key to the bright
future that's the key to wealthy future
because when the government only think
about
money or
some profits
that's not the way people should treat
it
not the way
because people are the voice people are
the face of the government
so now the face of the government is
sitting in the prison
in uneligible court
so please save your face
i just want to talk about you for a
minute as well uh you're obviously a
young woman and you're from ukraine from
kiev
you're now in sheffield
your life has obviously been completely
upended and i'm sure like every
ukrainian
you know you have your own trauma and
your own stories um
tell us a bit about your story how did
you escape from ukraine have you left
anyone behind how are you
i feel terrible
i i cry a lot i've never cried so much
sometimes i feel like around my granddad
was
sinning no more tears left to cry
i escaped kiev
after um
[Music]
after
a week uh when the full-scale invasion
started i didn't believe that it would
last for a long time
but
unfortunately that's our reality it was
for long i do not really think it will
um
it will end in another half a year a
year maybe
so yeah i'm staying in great britain for
now
but escaping from kiev i left uh half of
my
huge family
in ukraine in newcastle city
hierarchy because my family is not only
about my relatives it's also about my
close friends
all the people i was surrounded in there
all of our community
all
the bright brightest minds
young brightest minds of ukraine
they lived there and my uncle with um
along with his child 11 year old
my cousin
uh they're now in the parisian region
and they constantly they can hear shelly
in their house is shaking and my
my heart tears apart from hearing that
honestly
all of our hearts go out to you as well
and um
and your loved ones who are still in
ukraine of course thank you so much for
coming on the program and telling
brahim's story i feel like you've really
painted a picture of the man that he is
so we appreciate that thank you
thank you so much for listening just
spread the truth
and protect humanity protect
yeah protect humanity protect people
democracy